le groupe air france numéro un en europe
les nouvelles règles du jeu européen et
du marché unique oblige donc la
compagnie nationale a trouvé deux
nouveaux associés
après une première offensive à l'est
cette fois c'est la belgique avec sabena
une participation donc de 37 5% dans le
capital de la compagnie belge l'accord a
été signé officiellement aujourd'hui à
bruxelles françois pub les mathis de
notre rédaction européenne aéroports de
bruxelles national arrivé du vol air
france 2010 en provenance de paris grâce
à l'accord signé aujourd'hui entre les
compagnies sabena et air france ces vols
vont devenir enchaînement de véritables
navette entre les deux pôles une seule
et même plate forme aérienne
prochainement la plus importante
d'europe
ainsi en complétant ses points d'appui
en europe de l'ouest et de l'est et en
agrandissant son réseau vers l'afrique
notamment le groupe air france se place
troisième transporteur aérien au monde
et le premier en europe
le mariage scellé aujourd'hui n'est pas
toutefois une absorption il respecte
l'identité de chaque compagnie
les etats unis le développement du
transport aérien s'est fait comment
dirais-je de façon cannibale les gros
ont mangé les petits on est en europe et
je ne pense pas que cela se passera de
cette manière là je crois que l'avenir
de la restructuration du transport
aérien en europe passera beaucoup plus
par des alliances des coopérations forte
par des relations de synergies entre les
entreprises c'est ce que nous sommes en
train de bâtir notamment avec la sabena
mais pas qu'avec la sabena
il est clair que si air france associé
avec la société tchèque csa si
aujourd'hui ils le font avec la sabena
belge demain il y aura certainement
d'autres types de regroupements autour
dé france et s'intéresse la sabena de
faire partie de ce grand groupe
la commission de bruxelles doit encore
donner son avis acceptera-t-elle ce
rapprochement
un veto n'est jamais totalement exclue
le commissaire brittan day mais on fait
valoir ici qu'un tel veto signerait la
condamnation à mort de la sabena pour
qui ce mariage est celui de la dernière
chance